people feel pretty disconnected at work
right now disconnected from their
organizations from their jobs and
especially from their colleagues you
might feel too burned out to do anything
about this last one or maybe think that
it doesn't matter but actually our
relationships with our co-workers play a
huge role in determining how successful
Innovative and happy we'll be at
work our work relationships give us two
valuable things social support and
access to information and research shows
it's the combination that can make us
happier and more successful I'm a social
scientist and I study how the way we
collaborate affects our well-being and
professional success I have a few tips
and you don't have to be a social
butterfly to give them a try Okay tip
number one build trust by opening up
having a close friend at work makes us
more effective at our jobs and
definitely improves our well-being if
you get along with your co-workers you
probably already have a sense of this
but our work friends are important for
another reason and it has to do with
access to information people people
don't just share their best ideas with
anyone we share with people we know and
trust I ran a multi-year study at Google
to find out why some teams are
successful and others fail and what we
found is that the teams who trust each
other do so much better because people
on those teams feel safe sharing their
best ideas so how can you start to build
that trust there's a concept called a
vulnerability Loop and the basic idea is
that when you're vulnerable in front of
somebody makes it a lot easier for them
to be vulnerable in front of you we
usually think you have to trust somebody
before you can open up but what this
research suggests is that often trust
comes after we've been vulnerable and
people have responded empathetically so
taking that risk to share that this week
you feel a little off because your
kids's starting at a new school or maybe
you're really worried about the status
of your big project that can actually go
a long way towards building a sense of
trust that can make you and your teams
much more effective okay tip number two
be a joiner surprisingly our closest
friends aren't the best people for
giving us access to new information it's
often our acquaintances because they
connect us to different Social Circles
and consequently new ways of thinking
social scientists call these
relationships weak ties and when it
comes to Innovation they're more
important than our strongest connections
for example in one study I found that
people who had many weak ties that
connected different groups in a large
organization were more likely to have
high performance scores more likely to
be promoted and even more likely to say
they were part of a creative
breakthrough the best way I've seen for
Dev veloping weak ties is to join groups
outside of your day-to-day work things
like philanthropic organizations sports
clubs or employee resource groups are
great examples you never know Tobin from
legal who you met playing pickle ball
might have a great idea that can really
help you out in your next project and
for leaders trying to spark Innovation
having a regular trivia group might be
more effective than the bestun strategy
Summit okay this last tip is especially
helpful for managers tip three make it a
little bit easier for people to belong
to something number number of years ago
I helped redesign the onboarding process
at a big company at the time the
onboarding week was maybe informative
but it didn't do a lot to create
meaningful connection so I ran an
experiment every week I assigned new
employees to one of five groups each
with a different color T-shirt and
something amazing started to happen
almost immediately people wearing yellow
t-shirts started having breakfast
together people in the green t-shirts
started walking between the different
sessions together and at the end of the
week we blew by our happy hour budget
because people hung out together so much
longer than they ever had the best part
is after that onboarding week many of
those people stayed in touch for years
which became a great source of weak ties
across the organization the reason the
T-shirt experiment works so well is
because it gave people an easy way to
identify the group they belong to you
could be creative here even things like
swag t-shirts and project codeen names
can go a long way towards creating a
sense of belonging look people feel
really isolated and disconnected right
now that's not surprising we've all just
been through a global pandemic the best
part about reconnecting is that it
doesn't just benefit you it benefits the
whole community that you help create